ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้
สวัสดีครับนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
เพลงกลับมาเรียนภาษาไทยกับเฮียตีและน้อง
เรียมเย็นๆค่ะ
วันนี้วันนี้เรามาเรียนภาษาไทยการวันที่
เท่าไหร่ครับวันนี้
วันนี้วันที่ 1 วันนี้วันที่ 1 นะโอเคใส่
เข้าไปค่ะเอาปากกามาเขียนวันที่ 1 อ่ะวัน
นี้วันที่ 1 วันที่ 1 เป็นวันอะไรครับวัน
นี้
เป็นวันจันทร์วันที่ 1 วันจันทร์นี่ครับ
วันจันทร์ที่ 1 เดือนอะไรครับเดือนนี้
เดือน
พฤศจิกายนพฤศจิกายนใช้ครับนี้เดือน
พฤศจิกายนเดือนนี้แล้วปี
นี้คศอะไรครับเอออีกคศ
2000  21 ใช่ครับปีนี้ปีคศ 2000  21
แล้วปีพศอะไรครับ
ปีพศ
2564 ค่ะปีพศ
2564 อยู่ตรงนี้อ้าว้าวววันนี้วันที่ 1
วันจันทร์ที่ 1 พฤศจิกายน
หน้าปีพศ
2564 เรามาเรียนภาษาไทยกันโอเคแล้วตอน
นี้ครับตอนนี้ตอนนี้ที่เราเรียนกันตอนนี้
กี่โมงครับ
อาหารแล้ว
9 โมงโม้ 9  5
นาทีหน้าแปลน 9:00 นใช่ไหมครับน้าค่ะซ่อม
วงช้าจะเอาโอเคอ้าว้าวยังเช้าอยู่เช้านี้
เช้านี้น้องเรียมน้องเรียมกินข้าวหรือยัง
ครับ
ยังค่ะยังไม่กินแค่อาเฮียที่กินแล้ว
เว่ย in แล้วอ่ะเราไปเรียนกันวันนี้วัน
นี้เราจะเรียนเรื่องอะไรกันครับหน้าเรียน
เรื่องอะไรการวันนี้วันนี้เราจะบอกเรียน
กันเรื่อง
กลัวตี้พีอาร์ตี้เปียตีหมี่รูปมาให้ดู
เดี๋ยวพี่เปิดเปิดรูปให้ดูอ้านี่ครับวัน
ดีดีเราจะเรียนเรื่องนี้เรื่องอะไรครับ
เรื่องอะไรในรูปนี้ในรูปนี้อ่าในรูปนี้
น้องเรียมเห็นอะไรบ้างครับเห็นอะไรบ้างใน
รูปนี้นะก็เห็นเห็นอะไรครับเด็กผู้หญิง
เด็กผู้หญิงอ้อคนนี้ใช่ไหมครับนี่เด็กผู้
ให้ค่ะหายเด็กคนนี้เป็นผู้หญิง
เด็กทุกหญิงอ่าในรูปนี้เด็กผู้หญิง
กำลังยิ้มยิ้มได้ไหม
ค่ะสวัสดีก็เห็นเด็กผู้หญิงกำลังยิ้มอยู่
นะแล้ว
ก็ชูมือขึ้นอ๋อชูมือชูมืออิ่มอกมือขึ้นไป
เนี่ยชูมือขึ้นไม่แบบนี้ชูมือครับผมขึ้น
แล้วก็ยกขาอ๋อเดี๋ยวขาด้วยยกขาอีกขาแล้ว
ก็ยกมือยกมือแล้วก็ยกขา
kk5
ครับผมนะก็กำลังก็กระโดดอ๋ออ๋อกระโดดยกขา
ชู้มือ
กระโดดหนีกระโดดขึ้นไปกระโดดนี้กระโดด
กระดกขวดอย่างนี้ใช่ไหมเขา
กระโดดกระโดดกระโดดค่ะเด็กผู้หญิงกระโดด
กระโดดอยู่ที่ไหนครับ
กระโดดอยู่บนเตียงอ๋ออ๋อกระโดดอยู่บน
เตียงอ่านี้ตีเรียงเปียงใช่มั้ยอะเด็กผู้
หญิงกระโดดกระโดดอยู่บนตียังวะว้าวเออ
กระโดดอยู่บนเตียง
แล้วมีผู้หญิงอีกคนนึงค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้มาใช่
มีผู้หญิงอีกคนนึงนักเรียนเห็นผู้หญิงอีก
คนหนึ่งไหมครับอ่าคนนี้เป็นผู้หญิงอะเด็ก
ผู้หญิง
แต่ก็มีผู้หญิงอีกนี้นี่คนดีคืนเงินผู้
หญิงผู้หญิง 1 คน 5 คนนี้โอเคผู้หญิงคน
นี้อ่ะเป็นยังไงครับผู้หญิงคนนี้ทำอะไร
เรียงคิดว่าคิดว่าผู้หญิงคนนี้เป็นแม่อ๋อ
อ๋อเป็นแม่ไส้ไหมครับอ่าผู้หญิงคนนี้เป็น
แม่
เรียมคิดว่าคิดว่าผู้หญิงคนนี้เป็นแม่อ้า
โอเคคุณแม่ของเด็กผู้หญิงใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะ
แล้วเด็กผู้หญิงเป็นอะไรครับ
เป็นลูกสาว
เป็นรูปลูกลูกสาวทำไมเป็นลูกสาวครับ
ทำไมเป็นลูกสาวหมอ
ว่าเออโอ๊ยลูกสาวขอลูกผู้หญิงลูกผู้หญิง
เป็นรูปสาวโอเคอ่า
ถ้าเป็นลูกถ้าเป็นผู้ชาย
ผู้ชายอ๋อถ้าเป็นผู้ชายเรียกลูกชายอ่ะแต่
คนนี้คนนี้เป็นผู้หญิงวันนี้เป็นผู้หญิง
เรียกว่า
ลูกสาวอ้าวเรียกว่าลูกสาวโอเคเออ
ส่วนผู้หญิงคนนี้เป็นแม่อ้าเป็นแม่คนนี้
เป็นลูกสาว
ว้าวคุณแม่เดินเข้ามาหาคุณแม่เข้ามาที่
ลูกสาวฮะแล้วคุณแม่พูดอะไรพูดอะไรกับลูก
สาวครับ
เรียงคิดว่าคุณแม่พูดว่า
ไม่กระโดดขอขอคุณแม่กำลังพูดว่าไม่ไม่
กระโดดอ่ะไม่กระโดดอ่ะอ่ะไม่กระโดดสินะ
โอเคเอ้ห่านอน
ให้นอนใช่ไหมเพราะว่าตอนนี้ตอนนี้เขาอยู่
บนเตียงนอนเตียงนอนต้องนอนต้องนอนมาตั้ง
แต่ลูกสาวไม่นอนลูกสาวไม่นอนลูกสาวทำอะไร
ครับเสากระโดดบทคุณแม่ก็เลยบอกว่าคุณแม่
บอกว่าไม่กระโดดไม่กะโจโหด 5k
ว้าวแต่ว่าเตรียมคิดว่าลูกสาวชอบสีชมพูา
ลูกสาวชอบสีชมพูมีอะไรน่ามีอะไรสีชมพูโทร
หาน้องเรียนมีปากกาใช่ไหมปากกาสีชมพู
หน้าครู Arty ครัวนี่ก็มีมีเสื้อ
เสื้อคู่อะตี้สีชมพูนิเสื้อสีชมพูลูกสาว
นักเรียนเห็นลูกสาวไหมลูกสาวก็ใส่เสื้อ
ใส่เสื้อสีชมพู
อ่าทรายแล้วน้องเรียมแล้วครับน้องเรียน
ใส่เสื้อสีชมพูไหมครับ
ไม่ค่ะน้องเรียวไม่ใส่เสื้อสีชมพูน้อง
เรียนใส่เสื้อสีอะไรครับ
สีขาวค่ะอ๋อสีขาวโอเค ami พี่อาร์ตี้ใส่
เสื้อสีชมพูลูกสาวใส่เสื้อสีชมพูอ่ะ
ฮะแล้วก็ใส่กางเกงสีชมพูอ่อนอี้ลูกสาวก็
ใส่กางเกงสีชมพูเหมือนกับเสื้อเสื้อสี
ชมพูกางเกงสีชมพู
ว้าวแล้วแล้วคุณแม่คุณแม่ใส่เสื้อสีอะไร
ครับ
คุณแม่ใส่เสื้อสีเหลืองอ๋ออ๋อคุณแม่ใส่
เสื้อสีเหลืองห้าสีเหลืองว้าวนี่สีเหลือง
เหมือนปากกาของน้องเรียม
โอเคอ่ะลูกสาวใส่เสื้อสีชมพู
พี่อาร์ตี้ใส่เสื้อสีชมพู
คุณแม่ใส่เสื้อสีเหลืองอ่ะไปค่ะยอมใส่
เสื้อสีสีขาว
โอเคอ่ะ
โป้นักเรียนอ่านน้องเรียมครับผมเห็นอะไร
เห็นอะไรสุขสาวชอบสีชมพูมีสีชมพูเต็มห้อง
เลยค่ะมีสีชมพู
มีสีชมพูเต็มห้องที่ไหนอีกครับมีสีชมพู
ที่ไหน
มีคมไฟสีชมพู
โคมไฟโคมไฟโคมไฟอ่ะอันนี้โคมไฟหน้าโคมไฟ
สีชมพูเพื่อโครงไปอาคมไฟเวลาก็จะมีแสงออก
มานี่เป็นแสงจากโคมไฟเออสีชมพูแวว
ขมสาวก็มีหมอนสีชมพูมีหมอนสีชมพูหมอนกู
อยู่ไหนหมอนอยู่ไหนครับนักเรียนอ่ะหมอน
หมอนอยู่นี่นี่ครับหมอนอ่ะอ่าหมอนสีชมพู
โอเค
ว้าวหือหน้า 6 สีชมพูด้วยค่ะมาห่มผ้าห่ม
สีชมพูงานนี้ผ้าห่มนี่นี่คือผ้าห่มน่าผ้า
ห่มสีชมพู
oh-my-zsh
อมพูผ้าห่มสีชมพู
โคมไฟสีชมพู
มีอะไรดอกเท้าสีชมพูรองเท้าเองรองเท้ารอง
เท้าสีชมพูตรงรอง
เธออยู่ตรงนี้มีมีรองเท้าสีชมพู
5 โอเค
มีรองเท้าสีชมพู
[เพลง]
แล้วอันนี้
อันนี้นี่นี่คืออะไรครับ
นี่คิดว่า
เป็นกางเกงอ๋อน้องเรียมคิดว่าเป็นกางเกง
ใช่ไหมกางเกงใจของกลุ่มภูชมพู
เป็นกางเกงอ่ะกางเกงสีชมพูอยู่ตรงนี้เนอะ
กางเกงก็สีชมพู
โอเค
แล้วลูกสาวคิดยังไงที่คุณแม่บอกว่าไม่
กระโดดลูกสาวไม่ชอบเรียนนางสาวช่อประดษฐ์
หาคุณแม่บอกห้ามกระโดดไม่กระโดดไม่กระโดด
อ่ะคุณแม่ก็เลยนะคุณแม่พาลูกสาวพาลูกสาว
ไปที่บทนี้นี่พาลูกสาวมาที่ชั้นหนังสือ
หรือหนีเป็นชั้นนะครับเป็นชั้นฉันอยู่ตรง
นี้
ในชั้นมีมีอะไรครับ
มีหนังสือหลายๆแน่หนังสือหลายๆเร่งโว่มี
หนังสือหลายเล่มหนังสือมีสีอะไรบ้างครับ
มีหนังสือสีเหลืองมีหนังสือสีเหลืองนี่
และนี้หนังสือสีเหลืองครับมีสีอะไรอีก
หนังสือสีฟ้าสีฟ้าหนังสือสีฟ้าและนี้นี่
หนังดีหรือ IE สีฟ้าโอเค
shark ซื้อสีชมพูก็มีหนังสือสีชมพู
หรือสีชมพูเล่มนี้หนังสือสีชมพูลูกสาวลูก
สาวชอบชอบสีชมพู
[เพลง]
แล้วน้องเรียมน้องเรียมชอบสีชมพูด้วยไหม
ครับ
ใช่ค่ะเรียงก็ชอบก็ชอบ
เฮียตี้เฮียตี้ก็ชอบสีชมพูวันนี้พี่ใส่
เพื่อสีชมพู
โอเค
แล้วเรียมก็เห็นหนังสือสีแดงห่อมีหนังสือ
สีแดงอยู่ตรงนี้ด้วยใช่ 5 มีหนังสือสีแดง
สีชมพู
สีฟ้าครับ
โป้
นักเรียนกำลังคิดอะไรครับเตรียมกำลังคิด
อะไรอยู่เรื่องกำลังคิดว่าลูกสาว
ข้างหน้า
น้อลูกสาวกำลังทำหน้า
อ้า
ทำหน้าสงสัย
สงสัยหน้าคุณแม่คุณแม่จะทำอะไรลูกสาวคิด
คิดคิดๆคุณแม่คุณแม่จะทำอะไรอ่ะคุณแม่จะ
ทำอะไรลูกสาวคิด
อ่า
น้องเรียมคลิปว่าน้องเรียมคิดว่าคุณแม่
คุณแม่จะทำอะไรครับคุณแม่จะทำอะไร
เรียงคิดว่าคุณแม่จะเล่านิทาน
คุณแม่จะอ่านหนังสือใช่ไหมอะไร
เหตุการณ์ทั้งคืนทาน
วิธานมีมีคุณแม่กำลังอ่านอ่านหนังสือ
นิทาน
น่าอ่านหนังสือนิทานให้ลูกสาว
หน้าแล้วลูกสาวลูกสาวทำอะไรครับตอนนี้ทำ
อะไรครับ
บองที่หนังสือลูกสาวมองที่หนังสือนะคุณ
แม่คุณแม่ก็มองที่หนังสือ
คุณแม่อ่านหนังสือลูกสาวก็ก็อ่านหนังสือ
กับคุณแม่อ่านหนังสือหรือหน้าครับเวียม
ค่ะอ่านหนังสือ
ด้วยไหมครับ
อ่านค่ะอ่าเตรียมก็อ่านอ่าซื้อ
ก็สวัสดีก็อ่านนั้นอื่นเหมือนกัน
นี้ค่ะถ้าครับแล้วนักเรียนนักเรียนอาหาร
หนังสือไหมเรียนอ่านไหม
อ้าวอ่านหรือไม่อ่าน
ใจครับช่วยบอกบอกตัวตี้คีย์ในคอมเม้นด้วย
หน้าบอกพี่เอ็ดดี้ด้วยครับใช่ค่ะพี่
อาร์ตี้คะเรียงเห็นในมือลูกสาวมีตุ๊กตา
ในมือมือมี
ตุ๊กตาอันนี้ให้ค่ะหน้านี้เป็นตุ๊กตาใช่
ไหม
ใช่ลูกสาวมีตุ๊กตากะตาเหรออ่อตุ๊กตาหมา
เดี๋ยวพี่อาร์ตี้ 5 ย้อนกลับไปดูนี่ตัว
นี้ใช่ไหมครับถ้ามีตัวนี้แต่ว่าอะไรนะ
ครับ
ตุ๊กตา
อ๋อ
ตุ๊กตาอ๋อเป็นตุ๊กตาตุ๊กตาตัวอะไรครับตัว
นี้ตัวนี้เป็นตุ๊กตา
ตุ๊กตาหมา
ให้ค่ะ Golf ตกที่เรียมเด็กๆนะคะก็มี
ตุ๊กตา
อามีตุ๊กตามเหมือนกันน้องเรียนก็มีตุ๊กตา
อามีตุ๊กตาหมาใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะมีตุ๊กตาหมา
ครับ
มีตุ๊กตามาเอาน้องเรียมเขียนเขียนไม่ได้
เขียนไม่ได้ใช่ไหม
ตุ๊กตามาหาคนขาโอเค
สตามหมาน
มีเฮเรารู้ทีมก็มีตุ๊กตาหมีแพนด้าหรอมี
ตุ๊กตาหมี
หมีแพนด้า
ตุ๊กตาหมีตุ๊กตาหมา
ให้ม้า
กระต่ายมีตุ๊กตากระต่ายด้วยใช่ไหมครับ
ว้าวตุ๊กตากันต่าย
น้าว้าวเป็นกระต่ายแล้วเป็นกระต่ายเดี๋ยว
พี่อาร์ตี้วาดรูปตุ๊กตากระต่ายอ้านจะตา
กระต่ายหน้าตาเป็นยังไงที่เราเครียดที่
ตอนเด็กๆตอนเด็กๆมีตุ๊กตาอะไรคะอ้าตอน
เด็กๆตี้ไม่มีตุ๊กตา
โป้ตีวะรูปตุ๊กตากลับอ่าใส่
ไม่เหมือนกับโอเคอ่ะอ่ะ
โอเคตอนเด็กๆพี่อาร์ตี้ไม่มีตุ๊กตาพี่ติ
ไม่เล่นตุ๊กตา
ในขาดนะโอเคหน้าตอนนี้ลูกสาวครับลูกสาว
กับคุณแม่กำลังอ่าน
อ่านหนังสือก็หนังสือนิทานนะครับๆตอนที่
คุณแม่อ่านหนังสือลูกสาวเป็นไงครับ
รู้ข่าวก็ง่วงงูอาลูกสาวก็หลับหน้าลูกสาว
ก้อนหลับนี่นี่หลับลูกสาวนอนหลับแล้วตอน
นี้นะครับนาคุณแม่ก็ทำอะไรตอนนี้คุณแม่ทำ
อะไรพ่อ
แม่ก็หอมแก้มอ๋ออ๋อคุณแม่หอมแก้มมีหอม
แก้มลูกสาวเขาลูกสาวหลับ
ลูกสาวนอนหลับสาวนอนกอดตุ๊กตา
หาว้าวนอนกอดนอนกอดใช่ไหมนี่กอดกอดตุ๊กตา
ก่อนตุ๊กตาก็นอนลูกสาวก็นอนนะอ่าทรายก็
นอนอ้าๆเรียนไม่ใช่ก็อยากจะไปนอนแล้วใช่
ไหมโอเคถ้าอย่างนั้นเดี๋ยววันนี้น่ะให้
น้องเรียมได้ไปนอนนะครับ
เดี๋ยวคราวหน้าคราวหน้าเราหน้าเรากลับมา
เรียนกันใหม่นะครับอ่าวันนี้เราได้เรียน
เรื่องของลูกสาวใช่ไหมเรื่องของสีชมพูลูก
สาวชอบสีเออกูน้าแล้วเดียวเรื่องของ
ตุ๊กตา
ตุ๊กตาด้วยมีตุ๊กตาอะไรบ้างครับ
ตุ๊กตาหมาตุ๊กตาหมา
ตุ๊กตาหมีหมี
ตุ๊กตากระต่ายตุ๊กตากระต่ายด้วยโอเคอ่า
เดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเรากลับมาน้ากลับมาเรียน
ภาษาไทยกับเพียวตีกับน้องเรียมกันใหม่นะ
ครับว่าจะเรามาเราจะมาเรียนเรื่องอะไรนะ
เดี๋ยวมาเจอกันคราวหน้างานสำหรับวันนี้
อ่ะ
ขอบคุณและสวัสดีนะคะนักเรียนทุกคนผมอา
ซื้อค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้สวัสดีน้องเรียนจ้าครับ
ผมบ๊ายบาย
ไปนอนให้น้องเรียมไปนอนพี่อะตี้ปาร์ตี้ไป
นอน OK คะเดี๋ยวทุกคนไปนอนสวัสดีครับบ๊าย
บาย
ไม่กระโดดนะคะไม่กระดก